حان الوقت لتسمع القصه من وجهه نظرنا هكذا
تقول ذو قد ساسيكس ميغان ماركل في وثائقي
نتفليكس الجديد الذي يحمل اسم هاري وميغان
الجزء الاول من الوثائق المثير للجدل صدر
يوم الخميس الماضي
تحدثها عن بدايه علاقتهما وكيف كان من
الصعب جدا تفادي عدسات الكاميرا وتطفل
الصحافه هاري تحدث ايضا عن معاناه النساء
اللاتي يتزوجن ضمن اطار المؤسسه الملكيه
وكما جرت العاده احدث الوثائق ضجه كبيره
في وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه البعض كتب ان
الثنائي لم يضيف جديدا على المقابله التي
اجروها مع اوبرا ويمري منذ العام الماضي
الجزء الثاني من الوثائقي سيطرح في الخامس
عشر من ديسمبر تابع المزيد معه
خلال الاسبوعين الماضيين لم يبدا هذا
القصر قصر
حادثه العنصريه التي طالت مساعده الملكه
اليزابيث الرحله حتى اعلنت منصه نتفليكس
عن وثائقي هاري وماجن هذا الوثائقي الذي
تصدر عناوين الصحف كافه بلا استثناء وهو
ما قد يتسبب بصداع للعائله الملكيه التي
عاده ما تتجنب الحديث في امور العائله
الخاصه
في ايه بقى بعرس الثعلب
حلقات الثلاثه الاولى لا تقلوا عن ضجه
الاعلان الترويجي الذي تزامن مع زيارتي
ويليام وكيت الى امريكا فاراء الثنائي في
العائله الملكه ستنفرت مؤيديها لا سيما في
وسائل الاعلام
صحيفه المترو ذائعه الصيت التي توزع في
القطارات سنه هجوما عنيفا على هاري وماجد
سائله اياهم هل تضعان المال قبل العائله
واجابت عنهما قائله انه السؤال الذي لن
يجيب عنه
صحيفه الديلي اكسبريس
على صفحتها الاولى ايضا الى جانب صوره
لهاري والملك الراحله طلبت بايقاف ما
وصفته بالخيانه للملكه الديلي ميل والدليل
ضربه الراحله في حين تحدثت تايمز عن
انزعاج القصر من الوثائق ومعتضمنه
يا بذلك
حمايه للملاحقه الاعلام لها بحجه ان هذا
ما يحدث لكل اللواتي يرتبطن بالعائله
ويتحدث هاري عن فخره بان اطفاله مختلطوا
العرق وكيف انه فعلا مثل ماذا وترك كل شيء
لاجلها
النقمه على العائله حيث تقول انها مهما
فعلت كانوا شيء يجدون طريقه لتدميرها
في الوثائقي يبدو هاري ماخوذه بوالدته
وبالتشابه بينها وبين مدن من حيث التعاطف
والحنان ومن حيث الثقه والدفء هل يقول انه
سيفعل ما بيوسعه لتجنب تكرار سيناري
والدته مع عائلته الحاليه هو لا يريد
للتاريخ ان يعيد نفسه وربما ذلك هو
المفتاح الذي ادخله القلوب الكثيرين الذين
احبهم دائما في صباح العربيه من لندن
معروف عبد الحق
الشرير الرئيسي في السلسله البطاقيه هاري
وميجا او على الاقل الجزء الاول منها هو
وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه وليس العائله
الملكيه دعونا نتعرف على اهم النقاط في
الحلقات الثلاثه الاولى هل يقول ان الجميع
ذكريات طفولته لا تخلو من وجود مصوري
البقره
يطاردونه منذ ايامه في المدرسه وحتى بدايه
علاقته بزوجته
ظهرت الوثائقي وتحدثت لاول مره عن علاقه
ابنتها وهاري وتعتقد ان الاعلام يحمل
طابعا عن عنصريا
زوجته كثيرا من صفات والدته نفس التعاطف
والدقه ويقول ان استمراره في الاعمال
الخيريه نابع من الحفاظ على ارث والدته
بطريقه الاول بالملكه وهجمت بسبب تلك لقطه
تحديدا واتهمت بالسخريه من التقاليد
الملكيه لكن البعض راى انها تتحدث بشكل
عفوي لا اكثر
ورقم الانتقادات الا انا اخرين يعتقدون ان
المسلسل اظهر انهاري وماجن يشبهان اي شخص
اخر خاصه مع استخدام ارشيف الشخصي من
مقاطع وصور وفيديو لثنائي على كل حال
سالنا الناس في الشارع في لندن عن رايهم
في الوثائق الجديد وعن نظرتهم بها الهري
وماجد
[موسيقى]
افلام
يمكن
[موسيقى]
صباح يا اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ محمد اليوم
انا بدي اسالك بس سؤال
حسنين العاديين للمفارقه هما اليوم الحدث
والخبر سواء في بريطانيا او خارجها فكيف
نفهم نفسر الموقف الاول
الاساسي اللي هو لغز لكل الناس والمتابعين
لانه اذا كنت تحتاج الى الخصوصيه وترك
الالقابك الملكيه السؤال هو اليوم
ميغان حصده حوالي 100 مليون من وراء همم
باع السلسله الوثائقيه والتي عادت اليهم
بتكسب ماده من خلال قصتهم الخاصه التي
خرجوا بها امام عدسات وكاميرات الفيلم
الوثائقي فهذا هو الامر المحير حاليا لانه
لو لم يكن الامير وليام همم ذوق ذوق هاتان
الشخصيتان العملتان ما كان همم نتفليكس
دفع 100 مليون وفي اول يعني ارقام حول
المشاهده بلغت اثنين فاصل اربعه مليون في
يوم العرض الاول للسلسله
اه هو استاذ محمد
انت يعني تحديدا استاذ نادين هذه يعني
اساء البرنامج بشعبيه هري ومكانته كان
هاري ربما العضو الاكثر اا يعني الذي يحبه
الناس اكثر من اي شخص ثاني في الاسره
الملكيه والمؤسسه الحكم البريطانيه في
السابق وتحول فجاه ليكون عنوان على صحيفه
الصمت هاري همم يعني همم الناس تهريب او
هريء الكريه او البغيض همم وهي في اشاره
ولعب على العناوين لانه ب 2005 في شبابه
هاري همم ذهب الى حفل الى حفل موسيقي همم
متنكر بزي همم ضابط ناسي همم الماني
وبالتالي انتقدته الصحف في حينه ولكن ايضا
قالت انه شاب همم يعني مستهتر قليلا وهكذا
واما اليوم
ولكن اعاده اليوم الوثائقي وما يراه الراي
العام البريطاني بانه يؤثر او يؤذي
الملكيه البريطانيه اليوم الى ان يصبح
ماده هاري ماده دسمه على صفحه الصن
الشعبيه وهي الصحيفه الاكثر تاثيرا في
الاوساط البريطانيه والانجليزيه وبالتالي
هذا يعتبر الضرب لشعبيته التي كانت تزيد
على شعبيات الملك تشارلز وشعبيه الامير
ويليام اخيه والذي يقال او ينقل عنه بانه
مستاء للغايه من السلسله طيب يا استاذ
محمد اليوم يعني هاري عاش وعصر كل
البروتوكولات والعادات اللي تخص العائله
الملكيه في القصر الملكي يعني ما كان عارف
انه هو وزوجته المستقبليه سيكون مقبلين
على هكذا اموره لنفسها يعني ما كانت عارفه
وكانه الموضوع مفاجاه لها كيف نفهم هذا
المستغرب
التخطي الاعلاميه خليه الاعلام في
بريطانيا من زمان يعني من ايام وليد في
مضبوط عنده مساله او في سؤال بالرايس
اطرحه والراي العام البريطاني عن مدى حجم
التغطيه التي يستحقها اي قصه تتعلق بمسؤول
او شخصيه عامه او حتى شخصيه ملكيه اليوم
يعني هري ياتي وكانه عائد من المريخ
ليخبرنا عما يجري همم في الساحه الاعلاميه
البريطانيه ربما تحامل الاعلام بعض الشيء
على هري وميغا ولكن يعني هذا الامر عندما
تكون شخصيه عامه هناك استقلاليه تامه
للاعلام ليتناول اي ماده وها هو يقدم لها
العوامل والتفاصيل الاضافيه كي ايضا
يتداول الاعلام من جديد قضيه هاري وماجن
ولكنه ايضا تكسب ماديا من هذه
التداول او هذه التغطيه الاعلاميه اكيد
وكمان اليوم العائله الملكيه يعني على
المدار للسنين دائما انتقادات في شائعات
في فضائح هنا وهناك عن ليس جديدا عن
العائله الملكيه لكن هل بعد هذا الوثائق
يمكن ان تتاثر نوعا ما العائله الملكيه
وضعها لانه الملك تشارلز الثالث حاول ان
يجمع بين القلوب لحظنا خصوصا في فتره
جنازه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
ايام او الايام السوداء التي كانت ايام
وفاه الاميره ديانا كان هناك محاولات من
القصر لتركيب الامور اليوم على ما اعتقد
وهناك معلومات كثيره في هذا المجال انه
الملك تشارلز يعني يعني له علاقه حميمه
ومهمه جدا مع ابنه هاري طبعا ولي العهد
الامير وليام وهو يعمل في الكواليس لكي لا
تخرج هذه الامور عن حد السيطره همم انها
ربما ماده باسمه دراميه على يعني سلسله
وثائقيه لتكن ولكن لا اعتقد انها ستؤثر
همم في همم قلب او ارث العائله الملكيه
ومكوناتها حتى الان همم ربما اختارت مجنن
همم الخصوصيه والابتعاد يتعداء ولكنهما
ملابس
من باب الوا للتغطيات الاعلاميه
البريطانيه وهذه مساله جدليه لا تخدم
مصالح
بريطانيا نحن نشكرك جزيلا الشكر من لندن
الصحفي محمد شبانه شكرا لك
هذا الموضوع له جوانب عده سنناقشها هذه
المره من الجانب النفسي نذهب الى الرياض
الان ومعنى من هناك مستشار نفسي دكتور
اسامه نعيمه يسعد صباحك دكتور اسامه اولا
معنا في صباح العربيه وفي هذه الساعه
الثانيه منها
صباح الخير على العربيه
دكتور اسامه ضيفنا الكريم قبل قليل ذكر
على مساله وكانه يعيش في المريخ اليوم من
ناحيه نفسيه هل يمكن ان نفهم ان نصور يعني
كانه الامير هاري وزوجته يعيشان في حاله
انك الواقع ام انه تمرد على الواقع من
ناحيه نفسيه ماذا
خلينا نبدا بالبدايه نقول انه العائله
المالكيه هي مجموعه موظفين لدى الحكومه
الامريكيه تقاضوا مرتبات مقابل القيام
ببعض الوظائف الاجتماعيه
ولديهم دعم كبير
طبعا انا اسف عند الحكومه البريطانيه
مرتبات مقابل هذه الادوار بضمنها الاشياء
اللي يجب ان يحافظ عليها من التقاليد
ملكيه يحترمها الجميع على مستوى العالم
السيده مركز من جهه الثانيه همم جاءت عبر
المحيط بافكار مختلفه وتربيه مختلفه وكانت
تعتقد انها ستكون الدم الجديد الذي يضخ في
دماء العائله هي هو ابناءها وحاولت ان
تتمص دور السيده الراحله ديانا سابقا لكن
مع الاسد لم يكن هناك تقبل له اشياء كثيره
ربما تكون واحده من عندها الاشياء اللي هي
تشير
الفني وربما زواجها المتعدده ربما
لكن على الطرف هي لم تبدا الكثير من
الجهود الانتماء
حاولت يعني تقلد حياه الاميره الراحله
ديانا
الحديث
عن انقل الى وجهه نظر الامير هاري هل
الامير هاري هاري ما زال يعاني من عقده
امه يعني في علم النفس كلمه الاسقاط يعني
يريد ان يكرر تجربه امه مع زوجته
همم الامير هاري الان غاضب مما حدث لوالده
ونهايته وكيف حاولت العائله حتى بعد وفاه
الراحل الاميره ديانا ان تتخلص من قرشها
كامل رغم كل محاولاته من يظهروا وهم في
هذهين فهو مستاء جدا كيف تعاملت العائله
مع ذلك الحادث ثم ما حدث بعد ذلك واستقبال
الملك الجديده في حياه الملك تشارلز وكيف
انه وجد انه ارث والدته تتقلصه شخصيات
اخرى وهو كان جاهز جدا لاي همم دافع خارجي
واظن انه همم السيده مركز
هذا الدور تحاول تقنعه ان هي ستحي ذكره
امه اكثر واكثر ولذلك هو كان متمسك بها
برغم انه خسائر كانت كبيره لكن انا عندي
لك سؤال
لو كان لو كان ما يحدث الان جزء من مؤسس
ان عاش اخبار العائله المالكه هل ستستغربي
بس العائله المالكه الان بحاجه الى
بانك حواليها عشان الناس تضل دائما
متذكره اخبارها وانه في دراما في الموضوع
وانه فيه ونفس الشتاء صار مع الكنز يعني
في النهايه
تقود بريطانيا
مليارات الدولارات من
دعايات والزيارات والسياحه ولم يحدث شيء
لم يكن متوقعا الشيء انه في 2.4 مليار بني
ادم اضاءه وقتهم يشاهدوا شيء مثل هذا مثل
ما قال احد الصحفيين المشهورين لا يختلف
كثيرا عن برامج الواقع الواقع الحقيقي او
همم برامج متابعه الكرديشن
مع هذه الكلمه ساخطب معك واشكرك جزيل
الشكر من الرياض استشار نفسي دكتور اسامه
نعيم شكرا